good morning John I've got a problem I
will still be alive in 2060 probably
that's when the population of the earth
probably peaked around 10 billion people
and also it's probably when we're gonna
start feeling the really significant
effects of global climate change that's
not a problem that's gonna be solved the
next 50 years it's gonna be a problem
when I die and when you die lots of
other problems will remain unsolved and
that's ok like no one has ever died
having solved all the problems it was ok
for them it'll be ok for us but that
doesn't mean that there isn't a path
that we should be walking down to solve
the problems eventually but if you like
before we can start walking down that
path we have to sort of agree that
there's a problem which we apparently
haven't done yet here are the top 10
arguments people use to say global
warming either is a de thing or isn't
caused by humans and my responses to
climate change is natural it's happened
before yes the climate has changed in
the past often due to an increase in the
carbon dioxide concentration in the
atmosphere which is actually a pretty
clear indication that increase in carbon
dioxide will increase temperature hanck
co2 concentrations only increase because
temperatures increased not the other way
around it is true that many warming
events began without carbon dioxide
levels increasing first however once the
warming began carbon dioxide levels
increased greatly amplifying the warming
of the warming events we have record for
90 percent of the warming took place
after the carbon dioxide levels increase
it's just that the sun's been getting
hotter no data these scientists are
using are wrong because they put their
thermometers in cities where there's
heat sources and asphalt to heat
everything up eating on the planet shows
up when you look at weather stations in
cities or in rural areas it shows up
when you look at satellite data or
thermometers that are sunk deep in the
ocean it's everywhere scientists are not
stupid the earth is actually cooling no
I mean it's not even it's not at all
2002 2010 was the hottest decade ever
ever on record but it's not warming up
as fast if you pick the years from 2009
to now the trendline is indeed not as
steep but the climate doesn't change on
the scale of years that's like looking
at a picture made of five pixels and
trying to figure out what it is it's
just not going to be very clear that's
why we look at decades and centuries of
data they predicted an ice age in the
70s small research team did say that in
the news media talked about it for about
two weeks but the vast majority of
peer-reviewed science during the
seventies said that the
was warming because of you guessed it
carbon dioxide emissions you're just
cherry-picking the data that support
your hypothesis data supporting global
warming comes from like every branch of
science whether it's biology with
animals ranging further north or
epidemiology with disease ranges
spreading or agriculture with yields
increasing in temperate areas increased
water temperatures decreased snowfall
earlier snowmelt rising sea levels but
Antarctica has more ice now than it used
to know but interestingly it does have
more sea ice than it used to there's
land ice the ice that exists on the land
of Antarctica which is a continent and
then there's sea ice which for the most
part forms in the winter and melts into
summer land ice the glaciers is what you
have to worry about and that is melting
at an alarming rate now why there is
more sea ice in Antarctica now than
there has been previously is an
interesting question one that has been
studied and here's a quick description
you could pause the video to read it
fossil fuels they're great on this point
I agree with you I think the fossil
fuels are miraculous they are a precious
resource I'm not gonna rag on anyone who
works hard providing inexpensive energy
and the freedom and happiness that it
provides but there are costs to burning
fossil fuel so we have to use them less
by choice and through hard work we have
to develop alternatives we have to be
more efficient and we have to change the
way that we live our lives but as long
as we agree that there is a problem I
have complete faith in humanity's
ability to solve it because solving
problems is what we do best John I'll
see you on Tuesday